raul castro quitte le pouvoir et passe
le relais à celui qu'il a soigneusement
formé à ses côtés depuis 2013 qui l'a
choisi pour ses qualités de leader
politique régionale mais aussi pour sa
fidélité à l'idéologie de la révolution
le mot d'ordre est continuité car
défigurer la politique intérieure qua
non la politique étrangère cubaine ne
changera pas et jamais le capitalisme ne
reviendra sur l'île je ne promets rien
dit il mais je viens appliquer le
programme d'actualisation du socialisme
et de la révolution
miguel diaz cannelle qui aura 58 ans
demain le 20 avril jeune moderne dit on
était tellement discret que peu le
connaissent
alberto juantorena est de ceux là le
double médaillé d'or du 400 et du 800 m
aux jeux olympiques de montréal
un exploit qui n'a jamais été répétée a
été ministre et trois fois député la
politique il connaît mieux dit as cannes
elle aussi est très accessible j'ai
souvent discuté avec lui il est très
intelligent il est jeune il sera prendre
ses propres décisions mais de manière
collégiale avec une équipe de son choix
comme tous les cubains alberto dit que
le grand problème c'est l'économie il
faut une transformation économique et
spécialement trouver un mécanisme qui
puisse nous élever donner à notre projet
politique
une valeur économique durable et
adéquate ce que raul castro n'a pas pu
faire on dit que ce n'est pas sa faute
je dois dire à raul castro qu est ce qu
il a fait qu'il ne plaît pas qu'elle ne
me plaît pas c'est pourquoi vous n'avez
pas éliminer les conservateurs
parce qu'ils avaient le pouvoir ça cela
dit viser pour dia scalese dia scanner
est-il libéral
ce n'est pas sûr il a déjà menacé
d'interdire des sites internet
d'opposition modérés et les parle pas
mal de le secteur privé mais pas de le
part le secteur privé bout
vous vous voyez qu'il est méprisable
deux secteurs ils disent qu'il y a
bon il ya la contravention classique ça
c'est fini mais il ya au noël
contributions sociales y sont mortes et
baisse à l'est les socialisme ou la mort
nous vaincrons
c'est ça la continuité dans son discours
d'adieu à la présidence raul castro a
dit qu'il avait entièrement confiance en
son successeur ce qui n'empêchera pas de
garder un oeil sur lui
à partir de son poste de premier
secrétaire du parti jusqu'en 2021
une tâche qu'il prend au sérieux
puisqu'il a dit qu'il allait se charger
selon sa propre expression de faciliter
la transition entre les deux générations
jean michel leprince sera du canada la
havane
[Musique]